[Music]
I'm excited happening up in here it's
pretty boring to me yes
[Music]
come forward
you and Nakia are not to play in the
catacombs T'Challa
I'm sorry Obama what is her own mother
I was forced to make a difficult choice
today you taught me that every choice I
can makes is difficult true but some
choices are harder than others I'm sure
you did what is right for Wakanda you
always do what a great king babar that
is why you will always rain always but
what about when I get old and gray and
past comes to carry me off to the
ancestors but then I'll be Panther now
beat them back with my Panther claws
[Music]
arena suit you could pick up a grown man
with one hand Aramis Festus is a pro and
he told me he was to order to carry the
mantle of Panda he would pass it to me
and just be king he told me he was too
fat to fit the suit
[Music]
I told him not to speak at the UN he
taught me not to trust the outside world
why did he change his views died it has
a way of making you look back on the
things that you have done
do you often look back at your time as a
wall dog no the outside world is too
unpredictable
everybody is Charlie so surprised Black
Panther video because the DVD is getting
ready to drop they're dropping all kinds
of bloopers and deleted scenes so it
provides some nice context given what
happens during infinity war so I know
there are a lot of questions about
what's happening now going into Avengers
4 I'll try to address that too but if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
because I wasn't expecting this I will
announce a new Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway winner during this but there's
more infinity war to come today but the
cool thing that's going on here
obviously the bloopers are really funny
but there are two separate scenes the
young T'Challa they gave a big shout-out
to bast the Panther God what happens
when bast comes to take me away the
movie kind of addressed the mythology of
Black Panther like you have Iron Man
largely a technologically based
character so his character is mostly
about science until he starts fighting
grimace looking characters with nutsacks
for Chin's but thus far Black Panther
and dr. strange have been our entry into
the more magic mythologically based
characters the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so it's only gonna push more into that
with the Black Panther sequel so I am
hoping that at some point he gets to
have a moment or a communion with the
actual Panther God but in this he really
just goes to the ancestral plane to
speak to his father but the other funny
moment of this is when he takes in the
heart-shaped herb for the first time and
comes back after seeing his father the
very first time that he goes the
ancestral plane and says he was there I
saw him I talked to him if they had this
long chat about why his father changed
his views on the outside world
referencing what happened during Civil
War
that was all about opening the borders
of Wakanda before you got into that
conflict the Black Panther later paid
off at the end of the movie where he was
like okay we're finally actually going
to open our borders but they make a
really sly joke when they talk about his
father passing the mantle of Black
Panther to T'Challa he says his father
said that he was getting too old so he
was just going to continue becoming King
like the young black panther in the
other clip is like you'll always reign
you'll always be alive in his father's
like yeah maybe don't hold your breath
on that but then Zuri hilariously says
that his father really passed the mantle
of Black Panther because he felt like he
gotten too fat for this suit but now
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen infinity war because we need to
talk about the aftermath of that and how
it's going to affect modern-day Wakanda
going into Avengers four because as far
as we know you know here we go
black panther has been turned to ash one
of the biggest surprises of the end of
the film like you think that it's gonna
be okay but then he disappears as his
arm reaches out to her so the Russos
recently confirmed my soul gem theory
that Gamora is inside the soul gem when
Thanos is talking to younger more at the
end of the film everything kind of looks
orange in there's that shrine that looks
like the one from her home planet in the
flashbacks
they also confirm that's the soul world
so when he's talking to this entity
that's young Gamora it's really a
manifestation of what's left of her life
force so at some point she'll come back
during Avengers 4 but what about all the
people that were turned to ash
particularly Black Panther if his people
regularly talked to their ancestors on
the ancestral plane after they're dead
so a lot of people were like hey wait a
minute if the Soul world is gonna be an
actual thing during the movie is that
where Black Panther and all these other
people went because we know they're
coming back and now that they're all
dead
Shuri is effectively queen of Wakanda
she's next in line for the throne there
were a whole bunch of questions about
what Thanos actually did when he snapped
his fingers like when the people were
turning to ash were they being killed or
were they being erased from existence
because that would really change the
timeline if T'Challa never existed since
the movie has been out for a little
while the directors have started talking
about it in more detail it sounds like
all the people that were turned to ash
were killed
so most of everybody will retain their
memories of them
the forces of Wakanda will still turn to
Shuri to lead them until they get Black
Panther back which is why I think they
put her in a costume like the dress she
was wearing that looks very much like
the Black Panther costume like look at
the lines it's made to look black so
it's like they're trying to remind you
hey Cherie is next in line for the
throne when T'Challa was exiled from
Wakanda for a little while in the comics
she was named the new black panther and
took the mantle up so I think the Russos
built a little bit of that into the
movie and the way they used the Sheree
character like they just want to wink it
that off in the distance without telling
you hey this is exactly what we're doing
early speculation what they might do is
as if Sheree takes the art shaped herb I
know there's a bit of a continuity
question because they burned a lot of
that at the end of the Black Panther
movie but remember a lot of that was
taking place right after Civil War so if
they brought some of it back they could
have enough for Sheree to take some so
that she can go into the ancestral plane
and speak to Black Panther spirit and
they can start to deal with what happens
going into Avengers for like we're going
to bring you back brother she can have
some moment with him because they
literally do something like that during
the Black Panther movie when he's
talking to his father except his
father's like it's my time I'm supposed
to be dead I'm not meant to come back
you have to go on without me and learn
to be king yourself obviously an
infinity war that's not the case these
people are not meant to die so when
you're thinking about communicating with
some of the people that they've lost
just think about the mechanics of how
the ancestral plane works in the Black
Panther movie and how the soul gem works
in the comics and how the movie depicted
that so what'll happen is is I was
originally planning on doing a Thor
Stormbreaker video hopefully that will
still post later tonight if I don't get
it out in time then I'll just post it
tomorrow morning no worries still plenty
of Marvel stuff posting in the next
couple of weeks
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video yeah Jane please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post that Thor video click
here for my Avengers 4 video and click
here for that agents of shield infinity
war crossover scene thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]